this video contains spoilers for
everything within the danganronpa
universe except for v3 if you haven't
played v3 than you're safe but be aware
that everything else is fair game
enjoy the video no matter how intensely
the stormy seas may batter me I will not
fall as long as my feet are firmly
planted and if you can't do it alone
just find someone to support you and you
can support them back that's how you can
overcome any storm hello and welcome to
danganronpa 101 serious breaks down
everyone and everything in the
danganronpa world and today we are going
to be examining the overly energetic
upstanding citizen the seventieth class
the ultimate moral compass
kiyotaka he/she martyr kiyotaka murray
better knows taka is an example of a
classic lawful good individual who
unwaveringly believes in order and
established rules as such he is almost
always seen in his trademark pristine
school uniform even on his days off and
his holidays because even relaxation
demands a certain aura of order in terms
of his outward personality taka has been
described as enthusiastic to the point
of angry and will generally take charge
of any given situation presenting
himself as a natural leader who
genuinely cares for his classmates and
who always strives for the most
efficient possible solution to any given
problem however naive that solution may
be at times it mean just for an example
upon the commencement of the very first
class trial taka simply suggested that
the killer raised their hand despite all
of this taka has a more sensitive side
and actually suffers from very low
self-esteem with a core desire simply to
make friends however he believes that
his general nature is more of a nuisance
to others however taka has his reasons
for striving forward in his own
unrelenting manner which can be traced
back to his grandfather Tora nosegay
each Amaru who at one point was the
Prime Minister of Japan and a man who
was widely labeled as a natural genius
as a result talkable Eve that his brand
father attained that position through
genius alone rather than any form of
hard work which may not necessarily have
been an issue until today Oscar got
caught up in a scandal and was forced to
resign as Prime Minister furthermore due
to the now deep mistrust of the Shamari
name their family business collapsed and
they were saddled with massive debts
which still had not been paid off by the
time we met taka and trigger happy havoc
but taka took his grandfather's Bailey
as a life lesson and resolved to restore
honor to the schmeyer family name
through raw hard work and would go on to
sacrifice integral aspects of his
childhood in order to excel at his study
and ironically Tucker's hard work and
dedication to honor would be noticed by
the talent scouts of hopes Peak Academy
and he would be designated with the
title of the ultimate moral compass and
accepted into the 78th class but
unfortunately as with all students in
this class when the tragedy struck the
world
this meant the taka would be sealed
within hopes Peak Academy to preserve
some semblance of hope for the world a
notion which was then heavily skewed by
his fellow classmate an ultimate despair
Junko Enoshima who erased their memories
and forced them to participate in the
killing school life killing game during
the game taka tried his utmost to
preserve the safety of his classmates
and rather notably taka would even go on
to make an unlikely friend in the form
of mondo owada although things didn't
start out you know particularly smoothly
here would talk a sense of supreme order
coming into great conflict with mando's
profound delinquency eventually
resulting in the two engaging in a
stamina contest where the two spent an
entire night in a sauna to see who could
survive the longest and this would prove
to be a great bonding experience as the
very next morning these two were
instantly best friends with great
respect for one another even going so
far as to refer to themselves as
brothers and after having made his first
ever friend taka would be horrified when
said friend was confirmed to be the
murderer of Chihiro Fujisaki in the
second class trial throughout the trial
taka was highly defensive Amanda and
even when it came time to vote and there
was no doubt left in anybody's minds as
to who the murderer was
taka refused to vote for mondo and
instead cast a vote for himself
following the trial taka was thrust into
a state of despair becoming near
catatonic that was brought back into
action upon discovery of alter ego whom
taka mistook for the spirit of the
murdered Chihiro in an attempt to
consult taka alter ego took on the
avatar mondo which well let's just say
it did not have the desired effect and
instead the sudden shock event occurs
mine sing mondo alive manifested his
grief into a strange new fusion
personality dubbed Kyodo as ki undertook
a sense of order became significantly
more aggressive and self-destructive
even going so far as to develop a
conflict with fellow student he Fumiya
mada / alter ego which would eventually
culminate in tacos ultimate fate in a
plot masterminded by celestial Edinburg
taka was lured into the science storage
room and bludgeoned on the back of the
head by who Fumi which killed taka
instantly and made his murder one-half
of a double bill that sparked the third
class trial which eventually culminated
in Celestia being found guilty and being
executed small fun facts about taka
despite being dead taka would go on to
appear in danganronpa
three as part of my coaches
hallucination along with the rest of the
departed members of the 70th class to
add to the great tragedy that he is
kiyotaka Ishimaru apparently the
developers were originally planning on
elaborating on his middle school life
however in their own words they stopped
because it looked like it was going to
take a dark turn and given our
familiarity with the danganronpa
universe one can only wonder what may
have been considered too dark to include
one of Tarkas Mora unique traits is also
his belief that when the body is naked
so is the soul meaning that in his mind
showing each other their naked bodies
helps two men form a mutual trust
despite it not being required taka had
an execution prepared for him should he
turn murderous and he found guilty which
was called Prime Minister Ashima Akio
Tarkas inaugural parade and it is
described as follows taka sits on a
vehicle announces peoples chairs in the
middle of huge gorgeous parade the crowd
has posters that say things such as
hooray for Prime Minister ich Maru in
the next moment monokuma pops up
resembling go-go 13 and kills him with a
shot through the heart and finally a
truly useless fact about underwear in
his school days taka was simple pure
white briefs which were his
grandfather's preferred brand of
underwear and allegedly support all
ideal Japanese men whatever that means
from down below but that pretty much
does it for kiyotaka Ichi Maru
if you enjoyed this video and the
content this channel produced in general
then please do consider donating to the
New World review patreon because the
support of all of your amazing people is
what continues to make this channel
possible and if patreon isn't quite your
style then please do leave this video a
like share or subscribe because it also
help support this channel an incredible
amount and if you'd like to join the fun
at any time and please do head over to
my discourse server where a wide array
of shenanigan takes place on a daily
basis and finally please do comment
through what or where you'd like to see
featured in the next danganronpa
[Music]
[Music]